dichtgedrängt klammern sie sich
aneinander
zwei mädchen invasion mänteln hinter
ihnen ein absperrgitter vor ihnen eine
horde von jungen männern die mädchen
werden eingekreist begrapscht belästigt
verzweifelt versuchen sie sich die
männer vom leib zu halten die
freundinnen sind 20 jahre alt student
innen aus deutschland die in italien den
jahreswechsel feiern wollten man hört
deutlich wie eine der beiden auf deutsch
um hilfe
[Musik]
sie sind nur zwei von inzwischen
mehreren frauen die in mailand anzeige
wegen sexueller nötigung erstattet haben
szenen die erinnerungen wachrufen an
diese westernach
2015/16 in köln auch hier war es ein
domplatz auch hier wurden unzählige
frauen im pulk heraus eingekreist und
sexuell belästigt auch hier kommt die
schande erst tage später ans licht die
mailänder behörden haben die
ermittlungen aufgenommen
an die 18 verdächtige seien vorerst
festgenommen worden bilder von
überwachungskameras helfen bei der
identifizierung der überwiegend
unmaskierten verdächtigen ebenso wie
damals in köln ist auch hier in mailand
nicht ausgeschlossen dass in den
nächsten tagen noch viele betroffene
frauen anzeige erstatten